welcome to this video playing s3
McAuliffe from from from Norway the snow
arid very weak day today with flat
guessing and okay the Italian game I
could I could play the Evans let's do
that I only have a vague vague idea
about the opening the deform I think
it's do you who takes and then castles
right
no Queen b3 actually Queen b3 yes yes
yes Queen b3 I recently had a brief look
at that for a correspondence game on
chess calm I'm playing some offhand
correspondence games on Jessica Queen f6
hmm
any better move than castling probably
not if it takes on c3 I'll play e5 young
Knight takes rook e1 looks very strong
yeah this isn't this the the classic
game fish against fine I had this in a
correspondence game as long so some time
ago I also made a video on that he five
and takes on new phone I'm not I'm not
not quite sure but Massimo speed on play
bit quicker okay I mean now takes e5 I
can I can just take it and take f7 this
exposes some his King far too much
probably there has an outright win after
that so
Queen Queen to g6
most likely yeah they haven't scam with
the small of them really interesting
sound gambits in 1 f 1 1 e 5 double king
pan openings there are so many damn bits
and most of them are not very dangerous
the heavens however they fully sound
like if he knows what he's doing should
be ok but it's it's notoriously tricky
and white really has substantial
compensation okay um take it right I can
just take it can take D form and Knight
takes Knight takes Bishop takes Knight
c3 is very strong development yes this
is the alternative but now I keep my my
strong Center and Bishop III and
absolutely essential resource resource
through a3 preventing him from castling
yeah I don't like this position much for
black he needs to be real precise now
maybe maybe something like d6 takes on
d6 Bishop e6 speeding up development
yeah move like that the Society says
maybe maybe a good idea of just tossing
a pawn to get to get stuff out increase
development yeah this is a good news
attic he is going to play 97 hmm
hmm I don't really want that is there
some alternative I really want to make
sure it cannot castle
okay that's it I don't want to also
don't want to have the position closed
so um let's let's do that okay look you
want Zack Bishop e6 that's just d5
winning it and here you know there
should be six is the threat right my
good Bishop g5 and maybe this is an idea
f6 Knight c3 yeah Bishop e6 I play d5
and he's caught in the e-file on the
e-file I think so okay d5 maybe Knight
takes d5 it looks terribly dangerous
okay you know I cannot give it a check
unfortunately how well do five is good
anyway
oh no it can't take let's let's
reconsider you can take worth the night
but I have queen bee five effectually d5
Knight takes Queen B five mm yeah he
cannot cancel
why should I just retreat him I'll get
them
I can't go here actually okay I'm down
to down to a little time mm-hmm
attacking d6 I can't just take it now or
is that big big drawback Bishop a5 maybe
could have been a big drama
the only issues I'm at the moment
slightly uncoordinated I need to decide
to move from badly doesn't have you know
it doesn't have a great move
they're not just complete development
and this is just happening check yeah
this is some essentially a piece for for
nothing
going to g3o III check check guys go
check got the King very passive I also
have the D pawn Knight f6 check okay
time warning check check check
yeah this is essentially the basic work
made just just with an extra night check
checkmate yeah this is a dangerous
opening for black and TM he didn't
really get a hold of the center of life
very hard too hard to say with this
limited time what the the problem was
I'm not I'm not sure at all about I
forgot the theory to be honest I think
here Queen g6 is the norm
but not quite sure okay I took and now
we played this one and well this is the
most straightforward move I have Bishop
e3 coming this is very similar to the
main line of this serve this I think
it's the same position just with the
Queen on d6 but I I don't I don't know I
never really looked at this for black
this line and this white I only saw some
game okay so he played this and now d5
yeah this is very interesting
d5 I think is a good defensive move if
it plays a passive move then after this
it's just not good let's say let's say
this one this is not easy to play for
black maybe can go d6 somewhere but very
tricky is an interesting if I took and
now he recaptures and I think maybe this
is the problem I was thinking about this
move and this is interesting and now
gives a check he is going to go c6 and
now let's say here intending d5 this
Knight f6 this is an interesting way to
play probably like as it's a very good
shape yeah an interesting way this show
gets gets very tricky to play and maybe
this wasn't the most precise with Knight
c3 is probably better yeah it's a patent
because now after Bishop e6 I have this
move without any any big problems
available and here gr d5 yam is just not
great I mean he can take it and what am
i doing now he's ready to castle and
he's got two pawns
now okay this is the battle and this
just gives away the piece I think you
just blundered that and it's not not
necessary and black can play other moves
I mean it's it's dangerous but it's even
this one it's maybe possible it's not
very comfortable but you can do that
can't say something like that gives
white very substantial compensation but
it's only a pawn I mean it's not like
two points or anything point of no
return type it's just one point yeah I'm
very interesting if the Evans gambit can
be recommended it so it's always
interesting to play thanks for watching